[Aplausos]
[Música]
vladimir putin lleva años alimentando la
idea de una rusia otra vez grande y
poderosa en la rusia actual cosas como
la prosperidad el nivel de vida o el
bienestar son secundarias lo que importa
lo que realmente importa es la imagen de
poder lo hemos visto con la terrible ira
que putin ha desatado en ucrania donde
no tenía nada que ganar excepto la
narrativa ahora bien como consigue putin
inocular este sentimiento entre la
sociedad rusa que está haciendo el
kremlin para impulsar el patriotismo
hasta qué punto se está utilizando para
ello al ejército hoy en visual político
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia habéis escuchado hablar del
ejército juvenil de rusia pues atento
pero momento antes de continuar te has
preguntado alguna vez cuando surgió la
industria financiera moderna has oído
hablar de la revolución que ha supuesto
la gestión pasiva no te pierdas el
último vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido el
canal de información financiera de
mutuactivos con el que participamos un
canal en el que próximamente te contarán
cómo es la gran apuesta por la energía
nuclear que está llevando a cabo el
gobierno chino os dejamos el enlace
abajo en la descripción dicho esto
continuemos
[Música]
y una armilla el ejército juvenil
los años que siguieron a la caída de la
unión soviética fueron muy complicados
para rusia el país cayó en la más
absoluta ruina la inflación se disparó
el rublo perdió la mayor parte de su
valor y las joyas de la corona del
tejido económico se las apropiaron los
oligarcas hablamos de unas dificultades
que también alcanzaron al ejército
[Música]
las fuerzas armadas rusas quedaron en
evidencia tras su intervención en
georgia en el año 2008 aquello fue un
auténtico punto de inflexión tal y como
os contamos en un reciente vídeo sobre
las fortalezas de rusia os dejo abajo el
link en la descripción tras esta guerra
putin puso en marcha una profunda
reforma militar para lo cual el
presidente ruso contó con una importante
ayuda
el precio del petróleo estaba batiendo
todas sus marcas históricas y llenando
con ello las habitualmente exiguas arcas
del kremlin ya no había que escatimar
así que el gasto militar ruso se duplicó
aproximadamente entre los años 2005 y
2018 y aunque no hay cifras confirmadas
oficialmente los expertos señalan que el
gasto militar ruso el gasto de verdad
supera los 50 mil millones de dólares
anuales aproximadamente un 4% del pib
ruso
[Música]
durante la última década rusia ha
realizado un importante esfuerzo de
inversión en nuevos equipos por ejemplo
durante este tiempo se incorporaron a
las fuerzas armadas más de 600 nuevos
aviones
840 helicópteros y 2300 drones el
kremlin ha renovado el 70% de sus cazas
y el 27 por ciento de sus blindados así
mismo la industria militar rusa también
ha desarrollado nuevas capacidades
tecnológicas en esta línea por ejemplo
se considera que las herramientas de
guerra electrónica de rusia que pueden
usarse para interceptar o bloquear las
comunicaciones y drones del enemigo no
tiene nada que envidiar a las
norteamericanas
pero esperando un momento porque al
gobierno de putin todavía le han sobrado
unos cuantos millones para hacer otro
tipo de cosas por ejemplo desde el año
2021 está en marcha un programa de
cuatro años dotado con
185 millones de dólares con un único
objetivo aumentar la educación
patriótica de los rusos sí sí lo habéis
escuchado bien entre otras cosas estos
planes incluyen hacer que al menos 600
mil niños se unan a las filas del yuna
armilla el ejército juvenil de rusia
[Música]
pueden entrar a formar parte de él desde
los 8 años hasta la mayoría de edad
desde luego el lunar milla es un digno
heredero de los jóvenes pioneros de la
edad soviética y es que veréis la
organización de pioneros vladimir lenin
fue la organización juvenil que utilizó
la urss para promover los principios
ideológicos del comunismo existió entre
1922 y 1990 que agrupaba a niños y niñas
de entre 10 y 15 años
alcanzó los 25 millones de miembros en
los años 70 la organización contaba con
los llamados palacios de pioneros
servían de centros de reunión donde los
jóvenes participaban en juegos trabajos
manuales y algunas actividades
deportivas luego en las vacaciones de
verano estos jóvenes acudían a los
campamentos de pioneros vamos eran como
los boy scouts pero con la hoz y el
martillo en la mochila pero bueno ahí no
terminaba todo al cumplir los 15 años
los pioneros ya podían formar parte del
komsomol otra organización para jóvenes
que les servía como puerta de entrada al
partido comunista eso sí respecto a la
época soviética el de una armilla de
putin no tiene vínculos con el comunismo
sino que se ha convertido en una
organización enfocada sobre todo al
ejército en ella se pone especial
énfasis en el patriotismo y en el
servicio a las fuerzas armadas con un
programa de entrenamientos que dirigen
oficiales de la reserva es más es que
hay una armilla tiene incluso su propio
uniforme
el uniforme 21 armilla es la clásica
indumentaria militar de color caqui pero
con un elemento muy característico en la
cabeza sus miembros lucen boinas rojas
con una insignia la que figura el
logotipo de una armilla ni más ni menos
que la estrella roja del ejército ruso
superpuesta en la cabeza de un águila
entre las actividades que organiza y una
armilla destaca en la práctica con
rifles y el aprendizaje de primeros
auxilios y la lucha con artes marciales
una vez al año el ministerio de defensa
ruso organiza el congreso de iun arminia
y allí amigos pues hay de todo mítines
nacionalistas armas expuestas por
doquier competiciones deportivas entre
sus miembros e incluso una feria
científica para atraer a los mas
cerebritos y muy importantes para crear
ambiente pues un dj y toca nuevas
versiones de las viejas melodías
patriótica saint debiendo efectos
propios y hip hop
todo con un objetivo mostrar a los
jóvenes rusos que nada mola más que el
ejército juvenil lo tienen bien pensado
seguro que todo es más atractivo que
insistirles con el solemne juramento del
de una armilla aviso a continuación
expondremos una versión reducida de este
juramento no sea que la versión completa
exalte en alguno un patriotismo ruso
inusitado fijaos juro luchar por las
victorias en los estudios y los deportes
para así ser un patriota y un ciudadano
digno de rusia pero un momento amigos
porque esta no es la única vía que el
gobierno ruso está utilizando para
fomentar la educación militar patriótica
entre los más jóvenes también financia a
entidades privadas que organizan
concursos con disciplinas tan
variopintas como el conocimiento de la
historia de rusia y otras más útiles en
un futuro de escenario bélico como la
lectura de mapas o las pruebas de tiro
con armas pero si hay algo en lo que el
kremlin realmente ha puesto todo eso
empeño ha sido en construir algo que sea
capaz de promover el patriotismo en toda
la familia algo que consigue emocionar a
niños y adultos por igual hablamos y
menos que todo un parque temático y
sabéis que prepara las maletas porque
nos vamos de viaje
[Música]
patriot park el disneylandia de rusia
los niños europeos sueñan con ir a
disneyland parís los norteamericanos con
ir a disney world en orlando pues bien
putin se ha propuesto que en rusia todos
quieran ir a patriot park y si está
claro que lo suyo sería que en este
parque hubiera montañas rusas pero
digamos que las intenciones del kremlin
van por otro lado si extraemos más
estamos hablando de un parque temático
militar dedicado al ejército ruso que se
encuentra en la localidad de kubica a
una hora en coche de moscú y ojo porque
el ministerio de defensa rusa no ha
reparado en gastos
para construirlo ha preparado unos 250
millones de euros y todo está cuidado al
más mínimo detalle por ejemplo dicen que
la comida consiste en raciones del
ejército y claro hay uno se pregunta si
realmente hace falta llevar a tanto el
realismo sea como sea lo cierto es que
el parque está pensado para el disfrute
de toda la familia aunque como suele
pasar con este tipo de instalaciones una
vez más la idea es impresionar sobre
todo a los más jóvenes eso sí al mejor
estilo de la rusia de putin en este
parque los jóvenes pueden participar en
actividades completamente diferentes a
las que estamos habituados a ver en los
parques de atracciones por ejemplo es
probable que los chavales estén hartos
de jugar a videojuegos bélicos con unos
gráficos increíbles pero videojuegos en
cualquier caso así que poder tocar un
arma de verdad e incluso realizar algún
que otro disparo es todo un reclamo
tampoco hay que menospreciar las
actividades como conducir virtualmente
un tanque utilizar una impresora 3d o
participar en el entrenamiento de perros
adiestrados
además en el patriot parte los
visitantes pueden ver de cerca un montón
de tanques vehículos de transporte
blindados o sistemas de lanzamiento de
misiles de todas las épocas digamos que
se hace un recorrido completo por la
historia bélica de rusia y ojo porque el
patriot part también es un lugar para
los negocios año tras año el parque
acoge una nueva edición del foro arm y
se trata de un evento internacional en
el que rusia exhibe sus últimos
juguetitos militares
[Música]
por supuesto sin perder detalle están
siempre las delegaciones extranjeras
enviadas por los amigos de putin al fin
y al cabo los principales compradores de
armas rusas son bien conocidos la india
vietnam china y bangladesh en asia irán
e irak en oriente medio argelia y egipto
en áfrica y nicaragua y venezuela en
américa en cualquier caso está claro que
este tipo de juegos siempre son un buen
lugar para hacer business o sea utiliza
una exposición de defensa para intentar
impulsar las ventas de armas a oriente
medio tienes un ejemplo pues fijaos
arabia saudí y emiratos árabes unidos
tienen mucho interés por las armas rusas
digamos que han tenido algún que otro
problema para comprarlas en otros países
o la guerra de yemen así que se dejaron
caer por aquí a ver que podían pillar
pero bueno esto es otra historia porque
la auténtica finalidad de esta
instalación es lograr que los rusos
contemplen todo el poderío de sus
fuerzas armadas
[Música]
por supuesto la victoria en la segunda
guerra mundial que ellos conocen como la
gran guerra patriótica es con diferencia
el principal argumento con el que se
apela a las emociones de los visitantes
hace años organizaron incluso una gran
recreación de la toma del rey estar
además en el parque también en un museo
interactivo que se llama mil 418 pasos
para la victoria estos son precisamente
los días que transcurrieron desde que
hitler declaró la guerra a la unión
soviética hasta el momento en que
alemania se rindió y si ya sé lo que
estáis pensando o seguro pero bueno a
ver a alberto si museos hay en cada
pueblo porque tiene tanto interés este
pues fundamentalmente porque todavía no
se ha hablado de lo más importante de
patriot park algo que nos dice mucho de
cómo es la rusia de nuestros días me
estoy refiriendo ni más ni menos que a
la catedral de las fuerzas armadas rusas
se consagró en el año 2020 para
conmemorar el 75 aniversario de la
victoria soviética sobre la alemania
nazi y su exterior es como cualquier
otra catedral ortodoxa salvo por su
color verde caqui pero más interesante
su interior en las vidrieras las
imágenes religiosas dejan su sitio a las
medallas de guerras soviéticas y el
diámetro de su cúpula principal es de 19
con 45 metros cifras elegidas
expresamente para simbolizar el año de
la victoria
[Música]
amigos hay dos detalles de esta catedral
que son a todas luces fascinantes el
primero es el suelo y no precisamente
porque esté hecho con mármol de los
urales que no es el caso la cuestión es
que a alguien del kremlin se le ocurrió
fundir armas y tanques incautados a la
alemania nazi para hacer los suelos del
templo el objetivo es que sean un día
visitáis la catedral de las fuerzas
armadas rusas a cada paso queréis estéis
pisoteando al vil enemigo fascista luego
el otro elemento más destacado de esa
catedral son sus mosaicos posiblemente
es uno de los templos ortodoxos que
reúne más mosaicos de todo el mundo pero
lo que los hace únicos es su temática
junto a las imágenes religiosas
hay otros mosaicos que hacen apología de
la historia reciente rusa como de
reciente bueno pues al final no tanto
como tenían previsto
o sea elimina un mosaico de putin en una
iglesia del ejército el diseño en el que
estaba ya trabajando podéis darlo en
pantalla pero se ve que al final les
parecía un poco heavy elevar a putin a
los altares al menos mientras sigue
siendo el presidente del país
[Música]
claro que el resto de mosaicos tampoco
tienen desperdicio están dedicados a los
ejércitos soviéticos y rusos hay uno muy
significativo en el que dos ángeles
miran desde lo alto a un grupo de
soldados con sus armas modernas una
lista conmemora una larga serie de
conflictos las intervenciones soviéticas
para aplastar la revolución de hungría
la primavera de praga o la invasión de
afganistán también se añaden las dos
guerras rusas en chechenia y otras
misiones más recientes que la propaganda
rusa domina como restablecer la paz en
georgia el regreso de crimea y la lucha
contra el terrorismo internacional en
siria y sabéis que otra cosa no pero los
rusos previsores ando un rato así que
han dejado sitio para añadir más
conflictos en el futuro si puede que
pronto se sume ucrania a esta especie de
recordatorio nacional claro que nos
falta quizás la pieza más importante de
todas atentos
la fortaleza sitiada
rusia sabe que ya no es la unión
soviética en tiempos de la grafía que ya
no es una de las dos superpotencias
hegemónicas del planeta pero putin se
resiste a tener un papel secundario y lo
hemos visto vaya que se lo hemos visto
en ucrania donde durante meses putin la
tuvo rodeada por tierra mar y aire hasta
que finalmente atacó todo para que se
siga viendo a rusia como una gran
superpotencia
y no perder de vista que rusia ya no
habla sólo de rusia sino también de los
otros países que formaban la órbita
soviética de este modo el gobierno ruso
lanza un mensaje claro cristalino que
todo el mundo sepa que los intereses
rusos no se acaban donde terminan las
fronteras de rusia algo similar defendió
a finales de enero el propio vladimir
vasíliev líder parlamentario de rusia
unida el partido de putin cuando pidió
al kremlin apoyo para los separatistas
pro rusos del donbass fijaos si se tiene
un proyecto creo que una gestión de
todos los contenidos que les público
vídeo ha estado con el ánimo y les dio
señales agresiva yendo production tax el
proyecto
espinoza fascista rostro y ojo porque
aquí tenemos una de las grandes claves
del marketing del kremlin el gobierno
ruso lleva años preparando a sus
ciudadanos para el conflicto para ello
presenta a rusia como la fortaleza
siquiera su objetivo es contención a los
rusos de que están rodeados de enemigos
y que por ello tienen preparaos para
defender a la patria con frecuencia
incluso trazar paralelismos con el
ataque que sufrió la unión soviética en
la segunda guerra mundial y claro desde
la comodidad del sofá de nuestra casa
podemos pensar para que exagerado se
esté putin pero lo cierto es que este
mensaje sí que cala en la sociedad rusa
vamos que si cala en una reciente
encuesta del centro levada de
investigación sociológica mirad cuál es
la segunda preocupación de los
ciudadanos rusos
más de la mitad de los rusos tiene
verdadero pánico a la posibilidad de que
haya una guerra mundial
ojo no una guerra nuclear ya una guerra
mundial es evidente que la propaganda
rusa en torno a la fortaleza sitiada
surte efecto y por eso titulares como
éste siempre son música para los oídos
del kremlin se insta a los países de la
otan a suministrar más armas a ucrania
el pretexto que putin necesita para
hacer lo que le dé la gana es el de la
seguridad y las supuestas amenazas
porque vamos evidentemente la mayoría de
los rusos comunes no quieren una guerra
los rusos son como tuvo como yo quieren
trabajar quieren prosperidad tienen
libertad
[Música]
pero claro ese patriotismo que lleva
décadas inculcando el kremlin hace que
los rusos se sientan obligados a
defender a sus hermanos rusos del
donbass
el éxito de la anexión de crimea en 2014
exaltó el patriotismo ruso y ya de paso
sirvió para que putin disimular ante los
suyos que la economía rusa ya no crecía
al mismo ritmo que a principios del
siglo así que he visto lo visto no
debería extrañarnos que el kremlin esté
intentando repetir exactamente la jugada
con una rusia golpeada por la pandemia
la inflación y las acusaciones de
corrupción en otras palabras que no
podemos descartar que todo el conflicto
sea una auténtica maniobra de
distracción
desde luego muchos más motivos no había
pero vemos hasta aquí turno para ti qué
piensas del ataque a ucrania déjame por
aquí abajo tus comentarios y si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante no
olvides darle al botón de like i
suscribirte abisal político un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]